No protectors here
this world will fall like all the others
I had a dream it was the end of the
world
he said the age of heroes would never
come again it has to
oh awesome don't engage alone
we'll do this together each of us
in some way is held back this is crazy
fighting the devil and his army in hell
this guy's probably fought hundreds of
thousands of other super beings on the
other planets he's destroyed right and
we have to assume he's won i don't care
how many demons he's fought and how many
hells
he's never fought us not us united
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my new justice league
snyder cut video for all the new scenes
that they just announced there's a bunch
of big news about all the dc movies
including batman stuff so we'll break it
all down if you're brand new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos we'll do a new amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber
and let me know what you're most hyped
up to see in the snyder cut
so just starting with number five big
stuff first zack snyder and warner
brothers announced that they're bringing
back
most of the main cast of the justice
league actors to film
brand new scenes for the justice league
snyder cut this fall
pretty soon actually they've already
been working on completing the movie all
year already
but this is a big deal actually bringing
back ben affleck as batman for brand new
scenes
years after they filmed the original
movie deadline variety hollywood
reporter all the big hollywood trade
publications are reporting that it's ben
affleck coming back for new batman
scenes gal gadot's wonder woman
aquaman in cyborg and that's it they
didn't list ezra miller's flash or henry
cavill so that means that whatever zack
snyder is doing with the flash during
the snyder cut he already has all
the footage of him that he needs henry
cavill also just did an interview
recently after this announcement was
made because he has a netflix movie
that's out this week with millie bobby
brown from stranger things
and per him he's already filmed all the
superman scenes for the snyder cut that
were necessary
way back when zack snyder was originally
filming the movie in 2016 and 2017
and on top of that they finally revealed
a more correct estimate for the actual
budget
of the justice league snyder cut movie
and it's way bigger than a lot of the
trades reported earlier this year
so number four most of you just want to
know what the new batman scenes are
going to be new wonder woman aquaman
cyborg
the way the trades are reporting the
announcement the reshoots themselves are
only going to last for around a week
maybe a little bit more
and even though i only mentioned those
four justice league actors coming back
to do new scenes there will be a bunch
of minor background actors and lesser
characters
all the headlines this past week were
really just about ben affleck coming
back as batman for new scenes with the
others but when you do reshoots there's
always a bunch of stuff going on in the
background of scenes too
but the only types of scenes that they
can finish in under a week like they're
doing right now are mostly just smaller
character moments where they're talking
to each other in exposition scenes like
smaller character moments
the news reports also didn't specify
whether or not the main justice league
actors would be coming back for their
new scenes at the same time like if the
new scenes will have all of them
together
in the scenes talking to each other some
of the scenes are probably them just
dipping in for a day or two
here and there in separate new scenes
it's really common for smaller reshoots
like this to happen when they're editing
the movie together and they find that
they need extra dialogue or small
moments to connect
to other scenes like wonder woman learns
the secrets of dark side in this old
greek temple
and you get that flashback scene then
maybe the cut suddenly jumps to batman
talking about darkseid they would need a
quick scene of wonder woman telling
batman who darkseid is between those two
scenes
to have it all make sense so that's
where your reshoots come in
also there's all the cyborg stuff cyborg
is kind of a special case in the snyder
cut because if you've been listening to
all the streams that zack snyder has
been doing between comic con and the
other conventions this year talking
about the movie
cyborg is supposed to be one of the most
important characters to the story
and he's barely in the theatrical cut so
not only is there a whole deleted
subplot with his character we've seen
some of those new scenes in the snyder
cut trailer from dc
fandom but zack snyder probably needs
more cyborg scenes with each of the
different characters to help
sew everything together he said that
cyborg is supposed to be the heart of
the movie and one of the core people
that brings the justice league together
and if you want to be really optimistic
yes they could use that week to film a
new post credit scene
as long as it's not too complicated i've
already done videos about the batman
green lantern post credit scene that
zack snyder had originally planned to do
i don't know if he was able to film any
of that back when he was first working
on the movie or
that's going to be some of the new
scenes that he adds back in and there
could be other green lantern stuff that
he does
during the reshoots but usually when
people ask him what's going on with
green lantern during the movie he's been
pretty quiet about it just to avoid
giving away really big spoilers
number three this is actually pretty
exciting the full budget that all the
trades are reporting for the movie is
about 70 million dollars that's
almost the budget of the joker movie
with joaquin phoenix
very different kinds of movies though
the joker movie was almost like a small
indie movie by comparison but that 70
million dollar figure is more than
double what the trades were reporting
the budget was
earlier this year that's a ton of extra
money and just to be clear that budget
isn't just for the reshoots that zack
snyder is doing that's for
everything in most of the budget
according to zack snyder himself is
going to be going to completing visual
effects the really hardcore
stuff on the footage he already filmed
but number two the other new batman
stuff that ben affleck is coming back
for
is for the flash movie flashpoint little
bit different from what's happening with
him in the snyder cut filming new scenes
andy muschietti is directing the flash
movie they're taking what zack snyder
did with the flash character
creatively in the justice league snyder
cut and then just building on that with
some creative changes and updates for
the flashpoint stuff a lot of you said
that you'd like to see them fixed the
way that the flash runs that's one of
the things that they will fix during the
flash movie in addition to giving him
the new costume
in the quote about rebooting the dceu
that the flash movie producers gave say
that the movie will restart
quote unquote everything but it doesn't
forget anything
so when they're talking about flashpoint
ben affleck's batman michael keaton's
batman
it means that they're going to be
changing some of the continuity in
service of bringing in the multiverse
and just retuning everything to add the
newer bigger movie characters that
they've added since the last justice
league movie like shazam and black adam
so that all the dc movies make sense
going forward
but i think it's important to remember
that they say that they're not
forgetting anything and that's just the
confirmation that they're not completely
retconning ben affleck's batman away if
you're a big fan of his version of the
character
i know there's some hardcore fans out
there that really want him to come back
for a batman hbo series
right now the only batman hbo series
that they've said that they're making is
matt reeves batman hbo series based on
the robber patents in batman movies
based on their production schedule they
probably won't end up releasing that
until after the batman movie comes out
next year so we might see the tv show in
it'll take place during batman year one
in robert pattinson's gotham
the batman movie will take place during
batman year two so if the show runs for
multiple seasons
they'll just adjust the timeline of the
show so that it stays
in batman year one it's the exact same
thing that marvel is doing with the
avengers shows on disney plus like the
Wandavision trailer that we just got
big movie crossovers with the tv shows
with the movie actors appearing in their
own shows
the budgets are way bigger than the cw
dc tv shows
and they do way fewer episodes there's a
ton of dc shows coming to hbo in the
next few years they've only announced
the batman series green lantern
the new suicide squad tv show justice
league dark
a constantine tv show an aquaman tv show
called king of atlantis and there will
be more but those are just the ones that
they've talked about right now
you probably heard about them slowly
canceling the cw dc tv shows that's just
because warner brothers is sort of
refocusing their attention on the big
budget
hbo dc tv shows but number one as for
the other cyborg stuff that's been
happening in the news there's been a lot
of cyborg in the news lately
despite all that the flash movie
producers say that he's still supposed
to appear
in the flash movie in some way but
apparently part of the dispute that
they're having with ray fisher
is about how many scenes he's supposed
to have during the movie
i'm sure they'll eventually work all
that stuff out and cyborg will still
wind up at least having some sort of
cameo during the movie
but apparently before they decided to
bring back michael keaton's batman
cyborg was just a much bigger part of
the movie so it's easy to see
behind the scenes in warner brothers how
they swerved on that when they knew they
were going to get multiple batman actors
back during the movie
including ben affleck's batman everyone
let me know in the comments though what
else do you want them to do
during the new dc movies with their
different versions of batman if they
have
three now technically you still have ben
affleck's batman you have michael
keaton's batman now you have robert
pattinson's batman as well
we're all still waiting for terry
mcginnis to show up in a live-action
batman beyond which supposedly they will
be doing with michael keaton's batman at
some point in the future so actually
we'll have four different versions of
batman
everyone click here to re-watch the
batman trailer a billion more times and
click here for that brand new avengers
Wandavision trailer
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!